hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to we got
two films to review today kids the goofy
1980s classics short circuit and short
circuit to a strange couple of films
about an annoying robot and a mattress
actor and a racist stereotype we got a
lot of movie to review and little time
to do it so let's just skip the intros
and dive right in all right no time
wasting let's just start the movie is
about robots so it starts off with
robots being made and there's one in
particular who will be focusing on
number five whereas it's technically
known Saint number five I don't know
number five of the Catholic do you
believe in the transubstantiation of the
Eucharist so we see a bunch of these
saint robots as they practice blowing
shit up during a military training
demonstration
huh must be a Pinto introducing your
host dr. Ford Marner I want you to meet
strategic artificially intelligent
nuclear transport our Saint as we call
it sure it turns out these machines are
built by Nova as they look forward to
having all the robots destroy evildoers
annihilate their enemies and surge in
attack your cocktail dr. Marner Thank
You number two they are destroying you
now number two we discussed this if the
question is survivable then st. is the
answer it is quite simply the most
sophisticated robot on planet Earth
yes but can it love so you might be
wondering just who made these Wally's of
death anyway well one of them appears to
be a white guy playing an indian guy
named
come on hurry up they're ready for you
friendly last time I am seeing him busy
warming things up will I have to go to
the jack so we wait for me this would be
incredibly racist that they didn't have
an Indian guy playing that role oh wait
they don't it's a white guy so yeah
that's incredibly racist and the other
inventor is Newton played by America's
first human representation of blandness
Steve Guttenberg he spends most of his
time creating technical achievements
that could revolutionize the world of
machines Heywood this one could give the
finger ah now what do they need me for -
tell him each robot cost 11 million
dollars and it kills people fed a child
- for Catan that that is my day are
needing you come on already up just one
dance isn't that cute I almost leave an
impression on you so as we can see from
this public relations get-together
robots are mostly used for killing and
stupid things please stop this constant
spinning it is an embarrassment to my
talents the only way you are the peace
senator as I'm sure you know I will
destroy you all
we can parachute but it turns out
Guttenberg isn't satisfied with how his
machines are being used dr. Crosby has
designed a weapon that will keep our
world safe for all time Howard what
still safe above blowing people up now
creating a machine that can give you the
finger that's inspired so the robots are
being packed up one of them number 5
eivin's be struck by light which
accidentally results in getting him a
soul same thing happened my microwave
last week now you won't shut the fuck up
you shut up yeah shut up so number five
it skips Nova and starts roaming the
outside world wow so many beautiful
things to kill so Gutenberg and a poo
are told to locate the wandering robust
let me get his outside the fence oh and
that is not the worst of it dr. Marner
don't tell me it's laser is still armed
bimbo you gather he says things wrong
it's charming so the military are called
in led by that asshole from police
academy as they try to hunt down number
five but they don't seem to do a very
good job tell my toaster I love her
a hell is this guy James bot
so he plants on top of a van that
belongs to a young woman named Stephanie
who apparently is having some
relationship problems we tell you the
truth I thought that maybe we could
patch things up I figure you owe me some
money
so I'm just here to collect I owe you
that's right I supported you what I'm
sorry I stole your hairstyle okay can't
we just talk it over
number five observes the female
Guttenberg and Hadji are told to find
the Machine and bring him back we're on
our way Howard to the great outdoors
Norton you know what is out there than a
great outdoors girls mm-hmm ears and leg
you have a working knowledge of girls no
but I read about them so this is uh no
declared war in the world huh by
releasing these guys actually this
should have been switched around Steve
Guttenberg and the Indian guy are the
creations that should have escaped and
the robot is sent out to bring them back
but oh well you make do with what you
got
so Stephanie comes across number five
who she mistakes for an alien and brings
him inside malfunction need input input
all right right you got it okay this is
a house we live within it inside we have
a floor see and we have the opposite of
a floor which is a ceiling this is gonna
be a long movie isn't it
this is a plan your taste in kitsch is
terrible input I'm giving you great
input my input my input ah
and like my input I have an addiction in
part so he searches around the house for
more input but begins to become a little
grating for dear Stephanie but bad Emily
guys but guess we you know why don't you
just anal probe me and get it over with
but while shelling him outside Stephanie
makes an incredible discovery Saint
prototype number five nova robotics
Damon Washington you're a robot
oh god I'm so stupid stupid foolish
gullible don't dish dumbbells lady shut
up silence
hushed sit down it dialogue Forrest
contrived annoying may stop please
so she called Nova and lets them know
that she has them robot but that doesn't
stop them from still having a few tender
moments together said I just called Nova
and they're coming out to get you
they're gonna give you a tune-up tune-up
no take you apart find out which screws
loose disassembled Jim
rats Afric disassemble reassemble ha
reassemble reassemble resurrect
Necronomicon ex Marcus I can't
reassemble him he squashed him he's dead
dead he suddenly comes to the conclusion
what disassembled meat
squash dead disassemble dead
disassembled excuse me Stephanie just
having a freak out so he tried off in
the car stephanie desperately tries to
calm it down crash road rage he kill her
manslaughter disassemble the world so
why do they finally stop the car number
five and Stephanie come to a stunning
revelation talk about about function not
function Stephanie number 5 is alive
tonight so Gutenberg and poppadom
arrived at the scene as they are shocked
to discover that number five was driving
the whole time well there's no way my
robot could have driven they call me a
liar no no uh but maybe you have amnesia
I'm funny
really so they decided to bring the
robot out and let him explain it he
really is in fact alive okay now you
just tell them what you told me
number five not just robots hey you're
upstaging my big cinematic moment
Academy Award winning performance lost
damnit stop hold your fire hold your
fire
II I cut all its power you can load it
on the truck now what the hell is the
matter with you you four-eyed idiot here
we're trying to blow shit up and you
come in trying to do sensible things so
they lull him onto the truck and
reassure Stephanie that they will never
see them again bye-bye goofy woman I
enjoyed repeatedly throwing you to the
ground
yay so they drive number five away when
suddenly well wait a minute how the hell
does this work he waits back up I
thought the color was hope and the faith
is alive
well yeah but technically there's no way
you can actually come back to light of
their faith is alive but even if you
kill a guy he can't come back from the
dead and the same is alive all right
fine number 5 is alive and then bang so
he gets out his weapons and friends the
two drivers to get out of the car or
he'll blow them to smithereens the two
of them wait on the roadside when
Gutenberg comes up and approaches them
later
hey honey what is for dinner graces
Indian guy we'll be right there
so as you would guess number 5 makes it
back to Stephanie's place at a rather
awkward moment that's Annie change color
hi boobies gazongas Joe's knockers meet
Festus but I know it's not safe for you
here so go on get out of here go on
lonely bum number 5 please if I went to
jail who would take care of my animals
what are you doing a can of soup a meal
in itself all right you can stay but
just for tonight
I guess you'll have me at soup as the
two of them hang out more they discover
they have quite an intimate relationship
together hey you know what your
you're not a bad dancer and seeing boom
you
he's like a mix between a vibrator and a
man who can't get me pregnant this is
every woman's dream come true so
Stephanie agrees to talk with Guttenberg
at a safe location as long as he comes
alone with no military number five comes
with but unfortunately more Saint robots
have been sent out to destroy stay where
you are
Wow what great military design they can
destroy tribes jeeps tanks Oleg comes to
mud that's when they all fall apart oh
yeah and rocks mud and rocks that seems
to be the only weaknesses of the super
destructive killing machines whether
different companies are building pieces
of shit hi I'm a man and I'm a PC I
can't do crap now what's you up you
westerly low back I have plenty more in
my lane impressions file so he burst in
to the bar and take Stephanie away
running from the evil military
and so just keep on trucking who's the
boss I pity the fool smarter you set me
up coffee I'm telling you right now this
little fart of a robot is beginning to
give me the red ass don't make me show
my own teeth
so Stephanie tries one more time to
reason with Guttenberg that number five
is alive by meeting him in the desert he
tries to think about how he can
logically prove that he's a living being
by telling what else a joke there's a
priest a minister a rabbi they're out
playing golf and they're trying to
decide how much to give to charity it's
a dreary stuffing whose work sense is
funny
God wants he keeps oh I get it
Oh he learned the art of humoring people
it's really true
spontaneous emotional response ha ha ha
well it can't put people off but I'm
still impressed I am Alive yes so we
realize number 5 is alive they have
themselves a kids even though they
barely know each other and they all live
happily ever after
oh yeah except in the military
so yeah that's kind of a downer they
just kill them when they find out he's
alive oh the irony oh wait a second then
duplicate them stole from all the spare
parts surprise twist ending improbable
plot point do ex machina so they all
right off to live in the acres of
Montana and then they finally live
happily ever after
that is until short circuited unless
it's titled Judgment Day I really don't
care so in the sequel we're fortunate to
be spared the eternal blandness of a
Guttenberg performance but we're still
lucky enough to get a little rest
oh yeah this is a highly sophisticated
robot for 1995 oh the Indian guys now
selling goods on the street that isn't
racist at all so it turns out Ben is the
hero of this version god help us as the
idea head of a toy company sees his
little robots and offers and money to
make more we could go maybe a 50-piece
or no I'm only charging 1995 a day to
rent I'm making a deal with con artists
on the street this can't possibly go
wrong so he teams up with another Street
merchant named Fred played by Michael
McKean as he actually manages to get a
factory to manufacture all the toys
however construction does not go well
destroy all yeah I want to cuddle that
on top of that there's also bank robbers
who plan to dig under the factory to
steal some valuable jewels
so they politely ask our two heroes to
leave
in the nicest way of probar can ask so
with everything destroyed how can they
rebuild the toys well their solution
comes a knocking at the door and enough
deliveries for one day pal
stand back I have a leg in half a vagina
ah it's a package and what should be in
the package but catchphrase viewing room
box look wait what the hell is he doing
there anyway oh listen
hey dear bed we decided that the only
way we could help us to send number 5 he
can build your toy robot but you know
how crazy he has for input so please
keep an eye on him good luck love
Stephanie and Newton oh come on if
you're gonna do that you might as well
tell them the real reason that he's
there and they're not dear Benjamin
we're too busy and expensive to be in
your spin-off Steve is making a movie
with a dog and a dolphin and I'm
starting a lackluster TV career so we
set you this robot please make a movie
about him by an acceptable so of course
number five or Johnny Five doesn't one
speak all now goes to work how does he
do building toys you be the judge I
can't help it I'm in a panic I'm Freddie
Evan oh man
this scene will look great in the
trailer so even though v is happy to see
Ben again he can't help but feel like
he's not one of the crowd it sure is a
ventriloquist dummy he isn't alive I'm
alive I'm a human being like you
he sure is made of paper mache and wood
and except for pretend he sure doesn't
have feelings I have feelings Wow
Mister Rogers is an asshole so 25 gets
restless and starts roaming the city and
if you thought the Indian guy was a
horrible racist stereotype just wait
till you see this
they'll just kick your ass no smoke
gonna kick your face not smokers kick
your balls
it's the Dominican Cuban Mexican gang
and you better watch out for they have
nunchucks ah
a fellow checker a so through some slang
bag talk with loco tricks Johnny Five
into stealing about a dozen car radios
yeah Johnny Five is an outlaw now fuck
that man - shit mask
meanwhile back of a factory that is not
very happy the friend let Johnny out you
lost number Johnny by August now you
stop fucking up your do you just say
fucking now you stop checking up your
quality - watch the potty mouth it's a
PG man you'll cocksucking shit whore I
ought to knock your fucking ass back -
Laverne and Shirley you dick sucking
fuck tard
I found this machine across the street
but luckily Johnny Five comes back and
just in time too as it turns out those
goons are back to try and destroy the
factory why are you Amy why try to
disassembly Johnny very bad humans oh my
god the Droid is cracked and you will
know my name is below yeah I lay my
vengeance upon I can't believe we just
got our asses kicked by Robby the Robot
so seeing a business opportunity Fred
actually tries to sell Johnny five but
Johnny's confused it's just what exactly
is going on but they cannot purchase me
cannot I am alive and endowed by my
creator with certain inalienable rights
what the hell that's like the most
accident-prone robot I've ever seen
it's like HIV by you want to take out
the garbage you shouldn't know that was
gonna happen um no this does not happen
a metal war machine cannot be supported
by a hang-glider
in what alternate universe is that
possible
huh I guess they didn't have enough
money to show me land oh well time to
get into more shenanigans so Johnny
dresses up like a mechanical flasher and
continues to wander the city he then
comes across up
oh no movie don't go here very different
I'm no no you're not no matter what you
may have done you as deserving as anyone
else
oh I mean it's not like you're a
mechanical robot or anything to have
questions need answer then cut the
compassion yourself don't send the
machine
so believer or not Johnny fine actually
gets arrested and put in jail just for
the crime of living all right oh this is
your last chance I need an adult Ben
comes around to claim him but Johnny
Five still feels like he's insignificant
Johnny Five used to become accustomed to
this feeling cuz this is the way life is
being usually since I am leaving in the
eye I too am a very much waited you're
from India so Ben explains that he
actually has a crush on the woman who's
selling their toys and he too feels the
loneliness that Johnny Five is going
through I can help you oh no no no I am
completely on elgamal I I cannot be a a
fast-talking saucily type person but in
the bookstore I scan many megabytes on
male-female relationships I could give
you input I have a Lane 86 Khan solution
so Johnny five decides to give Ben some
advice from a mechanical sign while Ben
goes on a date with Sandy but obstacles
seem to keep getting in the way and all
the guys I ever met were exactly the
same way talking Thank You Seth
okay okay god you're the boss but the
cover is blown has been confesses to
sandy what he was doing the whole time
you mean you've had someone prompting
you yes me so that's what's been going
on
you've been trying so hard been the
expense alone it's really sweet that's
the creepiest thing I've ever heard in
my life
you're charming so sandy likes this
strange stalker moment and decide to
give Ben a chance the day it was such a
success we talked it we danced it we
drank champagne we did page 37 of the
Kama Sutra but the bad guys are back as
they kidnapped Ben and Fred and locked
them in a Chinese restaurant Johnny Five
is distracted as their leader named
Oscar convinces Johnny Five to dig
through the factory and into the vault
number five is a moron meanwhile through
a really complicated series of
explanations then can only contact
sanding through phone believes not only
the same to figure out that it's been
but she actually realizes he's in
trouble follows the songs that he's
playing through the believes and
interprets them as directions this
woman's a toymaker she should be a
fucking suicide so Johnny fight breaks
in and gets the jewels for Oscar afraid
the robot might tell somebody I guess
Oscar chases him down and tries to
destroy him Johnny Five gets the drop on
Oscar and tries to figure out why he's
been had
Oscar enlighten me why try to
disassemble Johnny Five oh shit they're
making a boy
ah
you animals he's already dead so after
that fatal blow to your childhood memory
you see sandy rescue the guys but then
ironically get caught again by the
police friend Maja's to escape and go
looking for Johnny Five no one is gonna
be like all busted up or something's
gonna be limping or talking funny or
shit yeah
when did this get so freakin sad this
isn't Angela's Ashes it's fucking
short-circuit get a sense of humor what
did they do to you
oh good maybe write something uplifting
like still alive or hopeful Oh God
what the hell is wrong with this movie
do the film just go up its meds or
something I mean lighten up
so Fred actually does a fairly decent
job getting number five back together
even though his wife's panties beep
Wendling Johnny Five decides it's time
to strike back they took away his toys
they used him as a pawn they beat him
and they left him for dead
now we built recharged and incredibly
pissed off Johnny number five is ready
to kick some flabby white ass Johnny
number five in I Robot you dead
no more mr. nice pot it's all on
what do you think you're gonna do
pursuit capture car sorry
nothing can stop nothing would dare
you're never gonna find him they're long
gone fight them I will be thinking we
were run on a forward anyone died he
doesn't need battery fluid that uses
fuel let's tidy I robot you death now
play currently so after Johnny Five
takes care of the two goons he sees that
Oscar is getting away
he decides to head them off at the pass
and by the way I'm not playing that
music
that's really what the playoffs no no
Oscar you will not get away
never has a battle between a mechanical
death machine and a frumpy old fat man
seemed so epic what are you punishment
from God God is not here
there is only fog
so it appears Johnny Five has died Oh No
what's the only solution to bring him
back shock the hell out of his crotch
that'll wake him up
I'll be fine oh you put
so not only is johnny-five brought back
to life but he's given a new golden
c-3po suit and actually sworn in as an
American citizen that white ass trench
movie mr. crime mr. v tell us how you
feel how do I feel say with him now I
feel
and that's short circuit one and two
cool what a rush so how do these movies
hold up well I have to be honest while
they aren't technically bad movies I do
have to admit I actually do kind of
enjoy them Johnny Five is actually kind
of likable and even been for his braces
as he is is actually kind of likeable
too it's a guilty pleasure to say the
least it's silly but it's an enjoyable
kind of silly now if you excuse me
I still have some issues to sit with my
microwave leaving the lights on last
night it was your turn take my job start
with me I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have my number
helpful as shit you I'll you know what
give me a reason give it a reason